bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france qu'est ce qui a particulièrement
retenu votre attention dans ces échanges
tout à l'heure à écouter en fait ce qui
m'a surtout vraiment impressionné c'est
qu'en fait on s'aperçoit que depuis le
mois de novembre vadimir poutine ne
s'adresse pas voilà ce qui s'appelle la
communauté internationale mais à son
peuple quand il demande des garanties de
sécurité à l'otan et aux états unis
surtout il sait pertinemment qu'il ne
recevra rien de sérieux et en fait c'est
une manière de montrer à son peuple
regardez j'ai tout essayé j'ai essayé de
demander des garanties de sécurité pour
que les occidentaux tiennent la parole
qu'ils avaient donné à gorbatchev il y a
trente ans j'ai essayé de relancer les
accords 2000 j'ai accès à accepter une
nouvelle fois de de réunir le format
normandie avec les conseillers
diplomatiques et tout cela ne donne rien
personne ne veut faire appliquer les
accords de minsk et personne n'est
capable à commencer par emmanuel macron
qui avait promis un cessez le feu
d'obtenir de kiev un cessez le feu donc
tout ça était parfaitement préparés
parce que eh bien en fait les
occidentaux c'est comme hollywood sait
absolument pas original ils sont pas
particulièrement
prévisible et aujourd'hui vladimir
poutine déroule son plan et on comprend
ce qu'il a ce qui fait depuis le mois de
novembre il a préparé la population
russe il a pris les réfugiés les amis
dans une vingtaine de régions russes
pour montrer ce qui se passe réellement
dans le donbass et aujourd'hui on
atteint le point de non retour et le
plan de la dîmière poutine se déroule
sans accroc il faut il faut le dire
parce que selon vous les accorde à minsk
sont encore en vigueur aujourd'hui c'est
encore une réalité cette discussion
elles ont elles ont repris il ya
quelques semaines mais jusque là est ce
que finalement c'était encore la
préoccupation des uns et des autres pour
régler le conflit aux dons parce est en
réalité si vous venez au texte initial
des accords de minsk il aurait dû être
accompli en décembre 2015 or en principe
il ça fait déjà donc depuis
depuis plus de six ans que kiev
n'applique en rien les accords de minsk
et que les occidentaux font mine de
croire que la russie est signataire des
accords de minsk la russie n'est
signataire qu'en tant qu'observateurs
comme le fce les accords de minsk
concerne kiev et les deux républiques
autoproclamées donc de toute manière il
est évident et c'est ce qu'on répétait
les interlocuteurs de vladimir poutine
au sein du conseil de sécurité nationale
que les kiéviens ne sont pas prêts à
accepter les accords de minsk pour
diverses raisons notamment parce que
toutes les lois anti russe et anti
russophone qui ont été prises depuis
maidan serait automatiquement annulée et
que l'ukraine serait fédéraliser par le
fait que les deux républiques
autoproclamées obtienne un statut
d'autonomie et c'est ça qui en fait qui
a fait qui a fait qu'au bout d'un moment
les russes en ont eu assez ils ont vu et
ils s'y attendaient et j étais prêt que
kiev avait les mains libres prononcé
toute une série d'opérations de
bombardements de harcèlement de sabotage
tout au long de la ligne de front même
si kiev évidemment n'est pas capable
d'envahir le dôme basse militairement et
pour eux ils ont décidé de sonner la fin
de la récréation mais en fait en
principe il aurait dû sonner la fin de
la récréation en janvier 2016 lorsqu'il
est apparu clairement que kiev n'avait
pas l'intention d'appliquer les accords
de minsk et avait des dépasser encore
une fois l'échéance l'échéance c'est
décembre 2015 ce qu'on a entendu pendant
cette conférence 7 pensent cette réunion
du conseil de sécurité l'envoyé spécial
russe sur le conflit ukrainien revenant
sur l'enjeu du dombass dans ses
multiples discussions diplomatiques a
mis en avant
et bien le fait que le processus de
négociation autour des accords de minsk
eh bien on en est à zéro depuis 2015
c'est ce que vous venez de rappeler
vladimir poutine est allé dans ce sens
là aussi expliquant que le processus de
paix dans le conflit en ukraine n'avait
aucune perspective
dans les faits il était déjà mal en
point et vous dirais qu'aujourd'hui
quelle que soit la décision tout à
l'heure de vladimir poutine de toute
façon les accords de minsk était mort à
partir du moment où la russie ne
reconnaît plus la république populaire
de dawn est ce qu'il a un public
populaire de louanges comme territoire
de l'ukraine on peut dit estime
effectivement que les accords de minsk
et m sont morts mais qui les a tués ceux
qui ont tué les accords de minsk ce sont
les membres du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu qui avaient voté pour la
validation de ces accords de minsk donc
en principe ce n'est pas seulement la
russie qui devrait prendre des mesures
contre kiev ce serait la france qui a
voté également en tant que membres
permanents ce serait les etats-unis qui
ont voté en tant que membre permanent
pour l'application de ces accords de
minsk contre les accords de minsk auquel
tout le monde s'est opposée et dont tout
le monde parlait dont tout le monde
faisait semblant de croire comment s'est
malheureusement par la diplomatie
française par jean yves le drian que la
russie n'appliquaient pas les accords de
minsk alors encore une fois les accords
de minsk ne s'appliquait pas à la russie
la russie a répété maintes et maintes
fois que c'était à kiev de prendre des
des contacts avec donetsk est lougansk
il y avait d'abord d'ailleurs à la seule
à l'issue des accords de mines sont en
fait il y avait quatre groupes qui
devaient se réunir régulièrement à minsk
est avancée sur l'application de ces
accords hier un groupe politique il est
vingt groupes humanitaires il y avait un
groupe umanis
économique
le quatrième j'oublié mais c'était dans
des domaines comme ça extrêmement précis
et c'est sur ces groupes de contacts que
les choses auraient dû avancer entre des
représentants de kiev des représentants
de donetsk des représentants de lougansk
tous a chapeauté par le cce par la
russie est également parrainé par la
france et l'allemagne qui aurait dû
faire pression sur kiev c'est ce que
demandait la mire poutine c'est ce qu'il
a demandé manuel macron lorsqu'il est
venu de faire pression sur kiev pour que
kiev applique enfin les accords domine
c'est à dire échange de prisonniers tous
contre tous amnistie de tous les acteurs
de ce qui s'est passé depuis 2014 et
adoption de noix d'autonomie du camp de
base en changement de la constitution
ukrainienne
et enfin élections à l'intérieur des
républiques autoproclamées une fois que
tous aient la chronologie et comme très
importante et seulement après la
restitution de la frontière a donc à la
l'ukraine tout cela kiev n'a avancé dans
aucun des domaines et au bout de six ans
de retard et bien il était temps que
effectivement que que la russie prenne
une décision qui paraissait de toute
manière inévitable si on n'est pas
encore prise vladimir poutine va se
prononcer dans la soirée pendant ces
échanges tout à l'heure du conseil de
sécurité une alerte de l' agence
france-presse
est tombé paris demandant une réunion
des causes possibles du groupe de
contact sur le cessez le feu est ce que
vous pensez que cette réunion tout à
l'heure à moscou cette gravité qu'on
sentait dans les échanges et ce qu'elle
malgré tout pourrait agir comme un
électrochoc
pour les représentants qui font partie
du des discussions du format normandiez
qui vise justement à relancer les
accords de minsk je ne pense pas puisque
parmi les gens qui sont intervenus
pendant justement cette c'est ce que ce
conseil de sécurité vous avez dimitri
kozak dimitri kozak c'est le conseiller
diplomatique de vladimir poutine que
vladimir poutine a envoyé à la demande
d' emmanuel macron reprendrons contact
avec le format normandie donc vous avez
une première réunion qui a eu lieu il ya
à peu près un mois une autre qui a eu
lieu il y à peu près une semaine et à
chaque fois dimitri kozak a fait une
conférence de presse en expliquant mais
les français les allemandes on a
l'impression qu'ils n'ont même pas lu
les accords de minsk ils sont incapables
de donner leur position sur les accords
de minsk est ce qu'ils sont d'accord
avec les accords de minsk est-ce qu'il
faut les appliquer ou pas donc la
première réunion avait lieu à paris sur
six heures de réunion il ya eu une demi
page qui a été écrit donc en fait rien
donc les français les allemands demandé
quinze jours pour réfléchir car jours
après eu de nouveau une réunion à berlin
c'était la semaine dernière et de cette
réunion une fois de plus il n'est rien
sorti ni paris ni berlin ne voulait
faire pression sur kiev pour qu'ils
appliquent les accords de minsk parce
que eux-mêmes subissait la pression de
washington pour que les accords de minsk
ne soit qu'un espèce de mantra qu'on
allait répéter et dont personne en fait
ne voulait prendre réellement
connaissance encore une fois des
articles et de là nos logis de
l'application de ces articles donc non
on peut amener on peut plaire les
réunions de tous les groupes de contacts
possibles et inimaginables il est clair
que la russie a déjà pris sa décision et
que vladimir poutine a fait en sorte que
le peuple russe tout entier adhèrent à
cette décision que quelles qu'en soient
les conséquences et la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elles vont à
quelles vont être les conséquences en
fait et on va reparler dans un instant
vous restez avec nous xavier moreau on
retrouve tout de suite toujours en
compagnie de xavier moreau fondateur de
strates paul on attend donc la décision
de vladimir poutine il se prononcera
dans la soirée à priori concernant la
reconnaissance ou non l'indépendance des
deux républiques autoproclamées du
donbass qu'elle serait alors à les
conséquences
en fait dans la mesure où cette réaction
de la russie donc à la reprise des
hostilités sur le front est assez est
assez inattendu parce que vous aviez
d'un côté le récit occidental dont qui
nous attendait qui nous annonçait une
une invasion russe donc joe biden a même
parlé récemment et blinken qu'ils
avaient des informations comme quoi la
russie elle a attaqué la ville de kiev
où vivaient je cite trois millions
d'innocents on avait d'un côté les
russes qui avait dit clairement depuis
déjà plusieurs mois que si jamais
l'ukraine se décider à lancer une
opération militaire contre le débat
c'est donc en fait une opération
nettoyage ethnique l'armée russe
n'hésiterait pas à intervenir et l'a
finalement on a quelque chose
d'intéressant dans le sens où la russie
va reconnaître donc les républiques
autoproclamées donc ça c'était pas du
tout prévu dans le cycle des menaces de
sanctions et la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est qu'est-ce que ça va
entraîner est ce que ça veut dire que
l'armée russe va se déployer comme en
ossétie du sud où comme en abkhazie sur
les territoires contrôlés par la
république de donetsk et de et de
lougansk que si c'est le cas ça veut
dire que là effectivement on peut parler
d'une présence militaire russe en
ukraine sens des frontières reconnues
par la communauté internationale mais
c'est pas non plus une invasion puisque
d'ailleurs dans le narratif occidentales
on nous explique que l'armée russe est
déjà dans le dans de basses donc en fait
aux yeux des occidentaux qu'est ce qui
va changer et ensuite si on fait un
parallèle avec ce qui s'est passé
vis-à-vis de la crimée les sanctions
contre la russie n'ont pas et sérieuse
je parle au nom pas été prise après la
prise de contrôle de la crimée par la
russie mais après que le m h 17 soit
battu à mon avis par les ukrainiens mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que en soit le
fait que l'armée russe occupe les
territoires des républiques
autoproclamées n'est pas
nenê n'est pas ne va pas forcément
entraîné toute une vague de sanctions et
de toute manière pour en finir là dessus
si vous avez écouté la conférence de
presse commune que l'anr poutine a fait
il ya deux jours avec le président
loukachenko deal russie il a dit texto
de toute manière les sanctions il nous
le in des loups ils nous les mettrons
donc il n'attend rien de bon de la part
des occidentaux et la russie est prête à
tout dimitri medvedev a donné une
interview il ya trois semaines où il a
dit de toute manière quoi qu'il arrive
qu'ils achètent notre gaz en euros en
dollars ou en yoann ce sera la même
chose vous a vu également le directeur
de la sberbank la plus grosse banque de
russie qui a dit que avec ou sans le
swift est bien là la russie réussir à
travailler donc on est quand même face à
une russie qui qui a complètement
comment dirais-je changent et changent
changé sa position
qui visiblement est très intéressée par
les échanges et xavier moreau dernier
mot les échanges diplomatiques ils se
multiplient ces derniers jours c'est
dernières heures on a évoqué tout à
l'heure et cet échange entre vladimir
poutine emmanuel macron qui s'étaient
entretenus avant cela avec joe biden le
président américain avant de rappeler
hier soir joe kinnear poutine le
président russe est ce que si vladimir
poutine reconnaissez tout à l'heure
l'indépendance de ces deux territoires
est ce que ce serait un terme nets à
toute autre
discussion elles sont elles sont prévues
avec une rencontre entre jean yves le
drian et sergueï lavrov vendredi après
midi il rencontre aussi qu'on évoque
entre joe biden et le président russe
prochainement quelles vont être les
étapes après la décision de de verdi v
poutine ce soir si elle était favorable
à cette reconnaissance
écoutez je pense encore une fois comme
je dis si on regarde que la maintenance
à ces faits il est certain qu'après
cette reconnaissance il va les relations
entre la russie et les occidentaux vont
empirer même maintenant il faut que la
réponse soit proportionné parce que si
vous voulez si les occidentaux des pois
les seules sanctions réelles qui leur
reste c'est à dire en fait c'est le
swift 1 de toute manière
l'europe occidentale ne peut pas et
l'europe en général ne peuvent se priver
du gaz russe les exportations de pétrole
russe vers les états unis n'ont jamais
été aussi importantes qu'en 2021 donc il
n'y a pas beaucoup de moyens de pression
sur la russie les quelques moyens de
pression c'est les semi conducteurs
c'est à dire que les halls et les
américains oblige taiwan et la corée du
sud à cesser de vendre des des
microprocesseurs à la russie mais là
aussi la russie peut se tourner en
partie vers la chine qui a bien avancé
dans ce domaine là donc si vous voulez y
a pas aussi il n'y a pas beaucoup de
possibilités de sanctionner la russie et
surtout la russie en revanche peut
sanctionner sévèrement les pays
occidentaux et surtout l'allemagne dont
le qui dépend du gaz russe à 55% n'a
tout simplement pas les moyens de aussi
de sanctionner la russie donc je pense
que dans la mesure où on n'a pas assisté
à une invasion de l'ukraine et notamment
la prise de kiev où même la la prise de
rares coffe ou donner ça qu'ils sont des
villes kiev rares cov odessa sa part
logé c'est des villes qui sont prêtes à
rejoindre la russie demain sur leur
propre aux voiliers mais on n'a pas
assisté on a assisté simplement et bien
la reconnaissance
des lourds et de quelque chose qui
existe des facto c'est à dire que la
république populaire de donetsk est
celle de lougansk sont désormais ne font
plus partie de l'ukraine mais ça dans la
réalité pour y être allé chaque année
depuis 2000 15 je peux vous dire que
c'est c'est quelque chose de
l'incontournable donc après tout va
dépendre de la manière dont les
occidentaux dont certains dans une
partie de l'établissment américain une
partie des néo conservateurs français
qui contrôle le quai d'orsay mais sert
la défense de vouloir utiliser ça pour
essayer de recréer un rideau de fer avec
la russie mais le pire le pire n'est
jamais certain de toute manière on va
être fixée je pense d'ici la semaine
prochaine sur le niveau de réaction
qu'on va avoir ce qui est clair en tout
cas c'est que c'est un échec pour joe
biden c'est un échec pour emmanuel
macron c'est un et c'est un échec pour
zelensky aujourd'hui le pouvoir du
président céline ski en ukraine est
vraiment vraiment fragilisé et tout peut
arriver y compris un soulèvement des
milices ultranationaliste ukrainienne
par exemple merci beaucoup pour votre
regard sur la question de l'indépendance
notamment des républiques autoproclamées
de lougansk de donetsk et merci xavier
moreau fondateur de strasbourg